everyone in the world has gone to bed
one night our mother with fear of pain
or loss or disappointment and he had
each of us as ablation arisen somehow
made our ablutions seen other human
beings and said morning how are you fine
thanks in you it's amazing
wherever that abides in the human being
there is the nobleness of the human
spirit decided on black and white Asian
Spanish Native American pretty claim
thin fat vowed a celibate realize you
may write me down in history with your
bitter twisted lies
you may tribe me in the very dirt but
still like dust Allah does my sassiness
upset you why are you but set with
gluing because I walk like I've got oil
wells pumping in my living room just
like moon and Suns with the certainty of
tides just like hopes and springing high
still I rise did you want to see me
broken bowed head and lowered eyes
shoulders falling down like teardrops
we can buy my soul
does my haughtiness offend you don't you
take it awful hard because I left like
I've got gold mines digging in my own
backyard you can shoot me with your
words you can cut me with your life you
can kill me with your hatefulness but
just like life I laugh does my sexiness
upset you does it come as a surprise
that I dance like I've got diamonds at
the meeting of myself out of the huts of
history's shame I rise up from a past
that is rooted in pain I rise I'm a
black ocean leaping and wide Welling and
swelling a barren inside leaving behind
nights of terror and fear I rise into a
daybreak miraculously clear I like
bringing the gifts that my ancestors
gave I rise
I am the hole and the dream of the slave
and so
[Applause]
[Music]
you